Twelve things introverts are best at doing.
Six: Being great workers.
Alongside being great leaders, introverts
also know very well know when to take a step back,
and get the work done. They're attentive,
whole-hearted, determined, and motivated to always do their
very best.
Since introverts usually don't use their words,
or quick wit to talk them out of sticky situations,
they use their intellectual prowess to provide an
answer rather than an excuse. Hand them an extended
project and let them work alone in a comfortable enviroment
and you'll get incredible results.
Introverts need a little supervision because
they're always triple checking themselves, seeing the flaws in everything
and preparing every argument that could be made against their work
and working around it to avoid said confrontation.
These qualities make them effective followers as well
being dedicated to the completion of their responsibility,
provided their solitude is undisturbed.
Seven: listening to your troubles.
Have you ever needed to vent? Confided in a close
friend and felt like they weren't really even listening to you?
That's the opposite of an introvert. Since introverts
know how hard it is for them to express their emotions verbally
if a love one expresses feelings to them, they will listen hard
and well.
Introverts are perfect for when you need a shoulder to cry on
or just someone to hear your story. As said earlier,
introverts hate small talk,
so if you go straight to the meaty, deep talk, they'll provide
an impeccable set of ears and even some incredible advice for you to follow.
Introverts are sensitive to pain; their own AND
others. They can tell when you're really upset or when you need
to get something off your chest. If a reserved
friend asks you if everything's all right, there's no need to hide
behind another "I'm fine, I'm just tired."
Go ahead and tell them what's bothering you. There's no better
support than that of an introverted friend.
Eight: counseling.
In addition to listening, introverts excel
at helping you cope with your worries. They can easily read people while others
are just listening, an introvert
analyzes and interprets the speaker's thoughts, actions
choice of words, and preconceptions.
They can notice little body expressions you don't even realize you're doing.
They can help you pin down exactly what's bothering you and even
suggest how to resolve it.
Unfortunately, many introverts are familiar
with pain and suffering, so they're quite experienced on how to alleviate any emotional pain you're going through.
Furthermore, calming someone down isn't all about
talking. It's about
understanding and making deep relationships built on trust.
Being empathetic is what introverts do.
Having someone there and listening and supporting you in a time of need
is just as comforting as a nice, warm hug. Which
many introverts may often initiate in moments like these.
Nine: Thinking before acting.
Introverts don't speak quite often, so when they do,
every single word was chosen
very carefully ahead of time. Sometimes
due to this introverts may take a while to get a sentence out
since they're mentally preparing and rehearsing each word
before they say it.
Since introverts take a while to express themselves,
many extroverts just ignore them and talk over them.
This can cause introverts to become even more shy
so that they don't get ignored again. As this is traumatic
and embarrassing. So if your introverted
friend speaks up, pay close attention because
what he or she has to say is probably important.
Ten: Knowing themselves.
We all know that quiet persons have the loudest minds.
Introverts spend a lot of time in their own heads.
From this they know themselves pretty well.
Aside from being silent critics, introverts
are constantly having inner monologues, evaluating themselves
and their choices in every day situations.
Thus they rarely have any existential crisis,
and can easily figure out their strengths and weaknesses.
They know who they are, what they want, and what is important to them.
They might just not tell you all of that information.
You could say that they're silent, but confident.
Eleven: Being a source of wisdom.
By nature, introverts love information,
learning, and discovering new things. They might not be the first
to go mountain climbing, but they'll definitely be in awe
over a new NASA discovery.
Their minds are constantly urging for more facts and things to ponder over
in the silence of their daily lives.
Not only that, but they use these interesting facts and
information to share with others when the time is relevant. So you never know
when your small-voiced friend might know the exact answer to
your problems after reading about a similar situation
months ago.
Twelve: Being a loyal friend.
Introvert friends will not betray you. They have no
reason to. They would never talk about you behind your back
or lie to you in a harmful way. Every secret
desire or dream you've ever shared with them will
always be safe whether or not the friendship lasts.
Introverts cherish friendships and no matter the circumstances,
would never betray someone who once confided in them.
They value relationships and try hard to keep them
which makes them some of the best friends you will ever have.
Introverts have quiet a lot of skills in those quiet
little bodies. If you're an extrovert, don't
be hesitant to communicate with silent peers
You'll be surprised at what they're capable of. And if you're an introvert,
be proud. You have nothing to feel inferior
about since behind that shyness lies a storm
of talents.
And that's all from us at Psych2Go!
Don't forget to like, comment, and subscribe for more.
Hey everybody! I just want to give personal thank-you video for you
guys for always supporting Psych2Go and making this all possible for us.
Our vision is to make psychology as accessible as possible
so that it promotes self-awareness and it helps you guys grow.
However, we want to make more content for you guys
and would love your support in buying one of these bracelets
from our partner, Introvert Palace. Check out the bracelet it's pretty cool
and it even includes Pluto.
The link to purchase will all be in the description below and I hope you guys have an amazing day. Bye!